[Applaudissements]
un petit vieux il va chez son médecin
pour faire un check-up à la fin le
médecin c'est pour avoir un check-up
global on a besoin de votre semence
voilà je vous donne un petit gobelet
vous revenez demain avec votre semence
s'il vous plaît le petit vieux il
revient le lendemain avec le petit
gobelet il est tout propre il y a rien
il dit qu'il s'est passé j'ai tout
essayé main droite main gauche rien n'y
fait j'ai même demandé à ma femme main
droite main gauche j'ai pas réussi à la
même essayer avec la bouche la pauvre
avec les danses sans les dents
on a demandé à la voisine il y a même la
moitié de l'immeuble qui est venu à main
droite main gauche personne vous savez
docteur personne n'a réussi à ouvrir le
petit gobelet
c'est la Coupe du Monde des signes
un Amérindien très calme cette année
tombe en finale face à un mec allant de
Marseille la finale commence et c'est
parti j'ai renimo il fait ça
sur
Alain a gagné bravo quoi ils vont voir
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah c'est très
simple j'ai commencé avec ma force il
est venu avec la résistance j'ai fait
l'unité il m'a fait la dualité je l'ai
fait la trilogie
je ne pouvais rien faire
et non c'est pas fini
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé c'est très simple il m'a dit
j'arrive pour te frapper j'ai dit chaton
[ __ ] il m'a dit je vais mettre un
doigt dans le cul
moi je te mets un troisième moi je te
mets jusqu'au coude il me dit il y a pas
la plage ne t'inquiète pas on va faire
la place
c'est un ancien préretraite mais il veut
continuer à travailler dans une boutique
bien gominée cosy mais il dit bonjour
monsieur l'homme je peux parler au
patron s'il vous plaît oui c'est moi
bonjour monsieur enchanté je m'appelle
Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des ventes en
France numéro 1 vendeur commercial je
vends tout ce que vous voulez dit non
mais monsieur on recherche pas de
vendeur monsieur s'il vous plaît je
m'appelle Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des
vendeur en France Laurent commercial je
suis meilleur pour moi bon bah ok il lui
sort important il dit voilà si vous
arrivez à vendre ça bravo la journée
passe il commence à vendre
cette journée il y a pas un truc qui a
été vendu le vendeur vient du bah alors
qu'est-ce qui se comment vous appelez
déjà Gérard Delmas numéro 2 des vendeur
en France je pensais que vous avez du
numéro 1 je fais énormément le numéro 1
celui qui t'a rendu cette merde
Samuel c'est un mec qui va chez son
médecin il lui dit docteur j'ai un
problème hier je la semaine dernière je
suis rentré chez moi un peu plus tôt et
j'ai vu ma femme dans mon lit avec mon
voisin je suis parti dans la cuisine
j'ai pris un couteau je vais les
trancher les deux je vais me trancher la
gorge et là docteur un self-control
docteur je pose le couteau je ferme le
tiroir je me fais un petit café je
réfléchis 5 minutes lendemain rebeloche
je reviens un peu plus tôt qui je vois
dans mon lit ma femme avec mon voisin et
mon cousin germain là je suis parti
prendre le pistolet je me dis je vais
buter tout le monde et m'envoyer une
balle j'en ai rien à [ __ ] et là
docteur un chef contrôle docteur
je pose le pistolet je ferme le tiroir
je me fais un petit café je réfléchisse
5 minutes le lendemain rebelote je viens
chez moi un peu plus tôt qui je vois
dans mon lit ma femme le voisin est le
concierge d'en bas je vais dans le
garage je me prends le fusil je vais
refuser tout le monde et je vais
m'envoyer une balle et là docteur un
chef contrôle donc je pose le fusil sur
le tiroir je me fais un petit café je
réfléchis 5 minutes et alors dites-moi
docteur c'est pas dangereux pour ma
santé tous ces petits cafés
[Applaudissements]
ils sont à Jérusalem devant le mur Moché
David mocher il est là il prit du jeu je
t'en supplie envoie-moi 5 millions
d'euros je vais lancer un petit business
j'ai juste besoin de 5 millions d'euros
à côté il y a David un peu plus simple
Dieu je t'en supplie j'ai besoin juste
de 100 €. j'ai même pas de quoi donner à
manger à mes enfants 100 € et écris plus
fort que David que moche avec ses 5
millions et dit je t'en supplie 100 € à
un moment je suis je me suis dit attends
tiens prends 100 € laisse de concentré
pour le vrai business s'il te plaît
c'est deux un couple Juifs vieux Salomon
et s'arrachent l'homo et non non non non
non
ah ouais tu veux la faire
et c'est Salomon il dit ça va ça va tu
sais quand on était dans notre village
en Pologne et qui a eu le pogrom ils ont
brûlé notre maison est-ce que tu étais
là il dit mais bien sûr mon amour bien
sûr que j'étais là et quand il y a eu la
Ralph du beldi ben ils nous ont tous
déportés auschwittes c'est ce que tu
étais là j'ai mis mon amour bien sûr que
j'étais là aussi elle lui dit après
quand on était à Auschwitz c'est qu'on
s'est évadé qu'on a marché trois jours
dans la neige et puis nazi nous ont
retrouvé nous ont ramené ce que tu étais
là et j'aimais bien sûr mon amour
j'étais là depuis le début j'ai dit
alors Sarah tu penses pas que tu me
portes un peu la poisse quand même
c'est Emily ratajkowski le connu sous le
nom de emrata elle fait une tournée en
Europe et elle a invité au Vatican elle
a reçu par le pape François elle lui
fait visiter la chapelle Sixtine tout ça
un moment le pape lui présente un
classeur et dire regardez comme vous les
mannequins on a un bouc avec tous les
books tous les prêtres d'Europe alors ça
c'est le prêt de Paris très gentil ça
c'est le prêtre de Varsovie très gentil
et ça c'est le prêtre de Turin et elle
voit le prêtre de Turin sublime une
petite bouche en cœur de Cyril Hanouna
mec
et elle lui dit mais lui il est prête
oui oui exactement il est prête et tu
rincé loin elle va il dit non tu as deux
heures elle sort du Vatican elle prend
la voiture et bah tu rends elle voit
l'église comme ça elle rentre dans
l'église elle le voit il est encore plus
beau que sur la photo elle lui dit toi
là-bas fais moi l'amour il dit quoi fais
moi l'amour il dit non mais Seigneur
c'est quoi cette tentation que tu
m'envoies elle enlève la robe comme ça
vas-y baisse moi baisse moi sur les
bancs il se retourne il se retourne vers
Jésus qui Jésus et qu'est-ce que je dois
faire Jésus est comme ça il dit
détachement [ __ ] je me la faire
oui
dernière une petite dernière c'est un
vendeur de boulettes à Tunis
il vient d'ouvrir le stand et toute la
Tunisie vient pour manger ses boulettes
un jour il rencontre une meuf et il
tombe amoureux mais il apprend que le
père de cette filière radiologue donc ça
fout la fout mal de dire qu'il est
vendeurs de boulettes il dit mais moi je
suis pharmacien j'ai quelques pharmacies
à Tunis le lendemain la fille elle est
avec des copines elle a dit meuf il y a
un mec il a ouvert des boulettes un
petit stand de boulette faut vraiment
qu'on y aille et ils vont avec les
copines elle est le mec il est de dos
comme ça et la fille a fait bonjour
monsieur Spar ciboulette il fait
ciboulette tout de suite il connaît pas
il arrive comme ça il voit sa meufs
alors ça sera de matin de midi et deux
soirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]